字幕: Arisa Takemura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
改めまして 皆さん こんにちは
切り絵師 俊寬といいます
切り絵を作って それを売って生活しています
皆さんの中には
「切り絵って何だろう？」
と思われる方も多いと思います
いわゆる普通の切り絵は
一枚の黒い紙を切って
絵の裏側から色画用紙を 一枚貼っています
すると 刃物で切った線が浮かび上がって
一枚の絵画が仕上がります
これは 私の作品の第一号です
学生時代に友達が切り絵をやっていまして
面白そうだったから
見よう見真似で作ったのがこの作品です
ちなみに私 美大出身じゃないんです
中京大学の経済学部を卒業してます
大学卒業後は会社員を
３年間やっていましたけど
違和感を感じたので そこを辞めまして
自分探しの旅に イタリアの
フィレンツェに行きました
紆余曲折の末
それまで趣味でやってた切り絵を
本職にすることにしました
初めての切り絵を作ってから 28年経ちまして
今はこんな作品を作ってます
今年の３月に完成させた作品です
ヴェネツィアの
サンタ・マリア・デッラ・サルーテ聖堂
サイズは 50×100cm
大体 これぐらいの大きさですね
黒枠で囲まれた部分は
一つ一つ色の異なるパーツを貼っています
屋根の部分の丸みをご覧下さい
一つ一つ色の異なるパーツを
絵の裏側から貼ることによって
切り絵の立体感や遠近感を表現しています
これが作品の裏側です
小さいパーツになると
３mmぐらいの大きさです
この作品全体だと
6,641パーツ使っています
このように かなり手間のかかる
やり方で作っているので
私以外でやっている人って
ほぼ いないと思います
ではなぜ 私はわざわざ
手間がかかる方法で作っているのか？
その理由には
イタリアで知り合った職人さん達が
大きく関わっています
フィレンツェに住み始めて５年目
当時住んでいた下宿の向かいにある
靴の工房の親方さんと知り合いまして
工房の見学させてもらったところ
実に面白い
職人工房が絵になる
ということに気が付きました
靴職人のカロジェロ・マンニーナさんです
日本でも有名な方なんですけど
それにおごることなく 常に謙虚で紳士的
職人としての技術だけでなく
人としても立派な方でした
この方の人柄に魅かれたことが
あとで私のライフワークとなる
職人シリーズを始めるきっかけになりました
その２年後の2002年
イタリアから引き上げたんですけど
ほぼ毎年イタリアに戻りまして
職人工房の取材を続けてます
職人シリーズは 100点を超えました
その中でも 今日は特に私にとって
重要な職人さん達を紹介していきます
彫金のパオロ・ペンコさん
金や銀でアクセサリーを作る職人さんです
フィレンツェで開かれたある展示会で
彼のブースを見たら
すごくかっこいいと思ったんですね
何と言いますか
積み重ねられた伝統の上に
さらに斬新さを感じたんです
この作品では
その時に感じた彼の
堂々としたたたずまいを表現しています
翌年
彼の紹介で その展示会に参加したんですね
フィレンツェで毎年5月に開かれる
コルシーニ公爵夫人主催の職人展でした
数多くの職人さん達と知り合う
きっかけにもなりましたし
2005年にはグランプリを受賞したので
私の切り絵師人生を決定づける
重要な展示会になりました
次は ブロンズのランベルト・バンキさん
ブロンズや真鍮で
写真立てや蝋燭立てを作る職人さんです
第二次世界大戦直後に 小学校を卒業しまして
それからすぐ 職人の世界に入りました
現在86歳
当時のイタリアでは
小学校までが義務教育だったんですね
この年齢で 現役の職人さんを続けているのは
このランベルトさんぐらいなんです
まさに 職人の中の職人ですね
今は息子さんが工房の代表を務めています
土日は休んでいます
私がフィレンツェに遊びに行くと
必ずおうちに呼んでもらって
お昼ご飯を作ってくれます
なので イタリアに出来た
親戚のような感じになっていますね
息子さんもお父さんによく似てて
一緒に時間を過ごしていると
こちらも幸せになれるような
すごく優しくて純朴で無邪気な方達です
４番目は 革細工の
ジュゼッペ・ファナーラさん
コインケースや名刺入れなんかを
革で作る職人さんです
何度かデパートのイベントで
来日しているうちに
親日家になって
40歳を超えてから
日本語の勉強を始めたんですね
今では片言の日本語で
お店の接客までこなされてるんです
ジュゼッペさん 初めて来日した時は
日本食がどうしても口に合わなかった
アテンドした日本人のお弟子が
お餅を食べさせようとしたんですけど
嫌がっちゃって 一口も食べなくて
もう見ていて気の毒なぐらいでした
で よっぽど懲りたのか
次の年からは パンをイタリアで買いまして
スーツケースの中に入れて
日本まで持ち込んで
ホテルの部屋でかじってたっていう
すごい悲しい感じだったんですけど
それが今ではこの人 親子丼まで
食べるようになったって聞いたんで
人間 歳を取っても変われる人って
いるもんだなあって思いました
紹介したい職人さんは
まだまだたくさんいるんですけど
切りが無いのでこの辺でやめます
フィレンツェモザイクの
ロベルト・マルッチさん
この作品では
生徒に指導しているところを描いています
この人 腕は良いけど
すっごく人騒がせで
困った人だったんですけどね
でも 彼にもまた
他の職人さん達に負けないくらい
素晴らしいところがありました
フィレンツェモザイクの世界って
すごく閉鎖的で
他人の自分の技術を教えるっていうことは
あまり聞かないんですね
でもこの人 周りの反発を物ともせずに
教室を開いて
数多くの生徒さんを受け入れたんです
６年前に この方亡くなっちゃったんですけど
この生徒が 今は独立して
自分の工房を持ってて
そして彼と同じように
教室を開いているんですね
志が受け継がれていっているんです
靴のマンニーナさんからは
謙虚さと人としての誇り
彫金のパオロ・ペンコさんからは
歴史の重みと
その上に新しい物を作るという心意気
ブロンズのバンキさんからは
日々の積み重ねと優しさ
革細工のジュゼッペさんからは
自分自身を変えようとする誠実さ
そしてフィレンツェモザイクの
ロベルトさんは
自己流を押し通すっていう個性の強さ
一口に職人と言っても色んな人がいました
2000年からこれまで
100人以上の職人さんを
切り絵にしてきたんですけど
なんで私は こんなに
職人さんが好きだったのか？
それは 彼らの作品は
もちろん素晴らしいんです
でもそれ以上に
彼らが仕事をしている時の表情とか
それから使い込まれた道具
彼らの人となりが表れている工房そのもの
それら全てに魅力を感じたからですね
職人仕事といっても その作業自体は
例えば 木や革を切ったり ヤスリで削ったり
釘で止めたり 糸で縫ったり
膠で貼りつけたり
地味な作業の連続なんです
でもどうなんでしょう？
真摯に向き合う彼らの表情の
なんとすばらしいこと
なぜに 彼らは このような大変な作業を
毎日続けていられるのか？
全員から共通した答えが返ってきます
「お客さんに喜んでもらいたいから」
これなんですよね
だから私も彼らの想いに
負けないように制作します
何も職人シリーズだけではない
モチーフが 風景でも人物でも静物でも
同じことなんです
切り絵って作ろうと思えば
割と簡単に作れてしまうんですね
で それなりの作品が出来ちゃうんです
でも中途半端なものって
そんなに人を喜ばせることって
できないんじゃないかなって思います
だから私は徹底的にやります
自分でもうんざりする程のパーツを作って
この作品を仕上げました
一切の手を抜かない
出来る限りの手を入れる
やらなくても良いことをやる
「いかに要らんことをするか」
これに勝負をかけています
ちなみに私 切り絵師俊寛と名乗ってますけど
キリエシってイタリア語で
「誰がそれを出来るのか？」って
いう意味なんです
正確には「キリエッシェ」
と発音するんですけどね
「Chi riesce?」
ちょっとイタリア人風に発音してみました
切り絵師という言葉に
イタリア語でも意味があることに気が付いた時
自分の進みたい方向とつながった気がしました
職人シリーズを描くとき
物が生み出される過程を描くことによって
彼らの人生そのものともいえる
「地味な作業の連続 」
イコール
「日常を積み重ねていくことの大切さ」を
表現できると思ったんです
彼らのように 地味な作業を積み重ねていけば
「誰がそれを出来るんだ？」
というほどのものを
目指していけるのではないでしょうか？
以前 シャツ職人が私に
自分の好きな言葉を教えてくれました
「手を使うのが労働者
頭を使うのが職人
心を使うのが芸術家」
アッシジの聖フランチェスコ
という人の言葉です
この言葉は
職人が 労働者よりも 芸術家が職人よりも
偉いという意味ではないんです
それぞれの仕事において
更に高いレベルでこなすには
何を使えば良いかということなんです
だから この言葉は
別に 物作りをしている人だけに
向けられた言葉ではないんですね
手と頭を使った上で 更に心を使えば
芸術的な仕事ができるんです
この場合の心とは何でしょうか？
それは「いかに他人を
幸せにすることができるように
それを使えるか？」っていうことなんです
現代の日本では 効率化重視で
みんな 気付かないうちに
いかに手を抜くか いかに楽して稼げるか
ということにとらわれて
大切なものを見失っているような気がします
だから私は 今だからこそ言いたい
敢えて 手間をかけよう
敢えて 面倒くさいことをやろう
敢えて要らんことをしよう
そうすれば
日常では気付かなった大切なものに
気付いていけるのではないでしょうか？
ご清聴 ありがとうございました
（拍手）